(rushing wind)
- [Narrator] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(upbeat electronic music)
- And in turn my pleasure
to introduce the second
of the Hitchcock lectures by
Professor Chikashi Toyoshima
from the University of Tokyo.
Toyoshima's group published
the first structure
of the calcium ATPase in 2000.
It's a large and unwieldy membrane protein
and determining the first structures
were both conceptional and
technical tour de force.
His group has subsequently
determined structures of the pump
in many stages of the
handling of calcium and ATP.
And from those structures Toyoshima
has been able to visualize,
for the first time in any system,
a process of active transport.
That's what he showed
us briefly at the end
of yesterday's lecture
and will tell us about in depth today.
Please join me in welcoming him.
(crowd claps)
- So today I'd like to tell
you about the calcium pump
in much more detail.
So, just for summarizing
yesterday's lecture,
so this is a kind of design constellation
of the calcium ATPase calcium pump.
So it's ATP powered pump,
and it has a very high
efficiency of energy usage.
And specific to calcium.
So that means it must have mechanism
for rejecting, for example, sodium ions.
And it must have at least two gates,
cytoplasmic and lumenal gates
in the transmembrane region.
It must have a mechanism that correlates
the chemical reaction that takes place
in the cytoplasmic region
to gating of the
transmembrane ion pathway.
And I show you that the
chemical reaction occurs here.
The actual binding site is located here.
And the gating occurs here.
And there.
And there must be a mechanism to correlate
that kind of small chemical
reaction to ion pathway gating.
It's a very long distance in transmission.
Intramolecular transmission is similar.
It's about 50 angstroms away.
I have to explain the
terminology of today's talk.
Essentially, we say the
active transport is achieved
by two confirmations of this enzyme.
So the E1 form it has
high affinity to calcium.
And E2 form, it has low
affinity to calcium.
So, the basic idea is that you have to
catch the calcium in the cytoplasm.
And then it occlude
these bound calcium ions.
And then open another gate here.
It's called lumenal gate.
And by changing the affinity to calcium
to a very low affinity,
it release the calcium.
So the basic idea is
the change of affinity
of transmembrane binding site
from a high affinity to low affinity.
Then release it,
the enzyme sort of achieve
the active transport.
During the reaction cycle,
the gamma phosphate of ATP
actually transfers first to enzyme itself.
So it is a phosphorylated state.
To stand for phosphorylated
state we use the term P state.
So E1P state means it has
high affinity to calcium
and it's phosphorylated.
And when that happens, the phosphorylation
also takes place in the two state,
and please remember,
only this state the lumenal gate is open.
To sort of understand this
kind of mechanism in detail
we have to crystallize the structures.
The key of the crystallization
is you have to fix the
protein in one confirmation.
So, in a way, you need inhibitors.
And this case, the calcium
itself works as inhibitors.
And here, we use the ATP analog AMPPCP.
And that's the phosphorylation state.
We have aluminium fluoride,
magnesium fluoride,
and beryl fluoride.
So, its fluorine complex act
as a good phosphate in analog.
That work was actually
done in this campus.
So, to stabilize E2 form,
so in this case, nothing
really stabilize it,
in the native form, then I
have to add some inhibitors.
The most famous one thapsigargin,
or benzohydroquinone,
or cycopiazonic acid, something like that.
So far, we got these crystals
at relatively high resolution
for the membrane proteins.
The best one is 2.1 angstrom resolution.
All of them (mumbles), I
can tell you the structures
better than 3 angstrom resolution.
Another point I should make,
is to make these crystals
I have to add a lipid
to mimic the native environment.
So the crystal actually like this.
So it's stacks of
two-dimensional crystals.
I showed this picture yesterday.
So this is a electron microscopy picture
of a cross-section of one of the crystal.
In the magnified view you see
the little areas going up,
going like this, and make sort of loops.
And even this area, you see
a very funny lipid loops
sticking out from the crystalline layers.
So it is curious that we have
crystals in which the ATPase
is in the lipid-like environment.
So this is status of February.
Before I started the
project I could imagine
that we may be able to get eight crystals
of different stages.
And so far we have succeeded
in, how many, seven of them.
We don't have this one
for E1P state structures.
But we know that these
three are very much the same
from limited proteolysis study.
And we can say that there
is no big domain movement.
So mostly I use this one
for representing this one.
So this one is aluminium
fluoride bound form.
So it's a transition state analog.
And ADP is still bound.
And the most recent addition is this one.
And I hope you remember
that only in this state
the lumenal gate is open.
And other state the
lumenal gate are closed.
So from these seven crystal structures,
by generating the intermediate structures,
by simple interpolation, we
could make these kind of movies.
So the calcium now get
into the binding site.
And the ATP comes in, and
phosphorylation takes place.
And the calcium get out.
That kind of things.
Of course, it's too quick,
and even I cannot explain you in time.
So I'd like to tell you
the mechanism step-by-step.
And also, these kind of
movies not perfect one.
Because we generate intermediate states
by simple interpolation.
Some funny things you can perhaps see.
But from these we can
address important questions.
The movement we saw so
large and complicated.
Why such large and complicated
movements are necessary?
And what does ATP do?
And what does phosphorylation do?
We can address these kind of questions.
This is sort of false
structure we got in year 2000.
So this is a calcium bound form.
And I showed this yesterday.
This is a transmembrane region.
It consists of 10 transmembrane helices.
If you look at the cytoplasmic regions,
it consists of three
very separated domains.
This one, at the center, it's
called phosphorylatioN-domain.
So it's P-domain.
And because these phosphorylation residue,
in this case it's structure is aspartate.
It's a kind of bacterial
type phosphorylations.
This domain locates here.
And N-domain is closed because
the adenine molecule of ATP binds here.
And A-domain was sort
of very ambiguous domain
at the beginning, but it turned
out to be a kind of actuator
of a transmembrane gating mechanism.
So I made perhaps correct naming.
So this is A-domain.
So calcium, as you see here,
it's located side-by-side,
although we know that calcium
binding strictly sequential.
Also, I'd like to stress that the A-domain
has sort of three links.
All of them look like flexible links
to the transmembrane regions.
Is it possible to write down?
Perhaps not.
Well, it's difficult to see perhaps.
This is the cytoplasmic region.
And this one is a N-domained
nucleotide binding domain.
And this center one is the
P-domain, the yellow one.
And this blue one, you can't almost see.
But it's a A-domains.
Well I hope you see that the
yellow helix is very long.
And starting from this lumenal end surface
to very near the phosphorylation site,
to the end of the P-domain I mean.
Another thing I'd like to
stress is that they are linked
by a very, look like, flexible links.
But from you, perhaps,
you can't really see.
I'm sorry about this.
Okay, so let's go into a bit of detail.
So this is a calcium binding site.
And now you are looking
at the cytoplasmic side,
approximately normal to the membrane.
So this one, the spheres
represent the calcium ions.
The two calcium ions, as I mentioned,
are located side-by-side.
And by looking at these
calcium, you perhaps realize
that their environment
are quite different.
The binding mode is different.
The site one is made by
all side chain atoms,
side chain oxygen atoms, like this one,
this one,
this one.
And two water molecules.
As I mentioned yesterday,
that the calcium likes
seven coordinations.
And certainly this case
the coordination is seven.
So seven oxygen atoms make binding.
And you look at the site two.
It's completely different.
The site two are formed by
main chain oxygen atoms.
Like this one,
that one,
and that one.
And the glutamate 309, this one,
it has it's carboxyl group,
so it has two oxygen atoms,
sort of capping this calcium.
So the site two calcium
almost sitting on the end
of a alpha helix.
And this glutamate sort
of capping this calcium.
If you are familiar with
the calcium binding protein,
that's quite reminiscent of EF hand motif
I mentioned yesterday.
So the most frequent calcium binding motif
found in soluble calcium binding proteins.
But it's very much the same here.
And also I would like to mention
that only one amino acid
residue, it's termed D800,
sort of bridging the two calcium ions.
And from site mutagenesis studies
we know that this site one
is a first calcium ion to bind.
And then the second one bind.
And that explains the cooperativity
of calcium binding pretty well.
Because when the calcium get in,
perhaps site two is not properly formed,
and so if it's properly formed
it must be trapped here,
but it is presumably not properly formed,
so the calcium can get
through this site to site one.
Then this perhaps this
D800 positioned properly
and allows the second calcium ion to bind
with the high affinity.
And the reason why this site
is the first calcium ion binding site
is explained like this.
So if you remove, say,
just one oxygen atom from
this one or that one,
you completely lose the
calcium binding ability.
But if you remove this one or that one,
you still have 50% of
calcium binding ability.
So the easiest explanation is that
this is the first calcium ion to bind.
Because if the first one cannot bind,
the second one cannot bind either.
But even you destroy this second one,
the first one is still fine,
if you have a 50% calcium affinity.
The next one,
I should look at the so-called
E1 to E2 equilibrium,
or more rigorous, the E1
calcium to E2 equilibrium.
For this, you add calcium
or some curating reagent
to remove calcium.
So this is a equilibrium process.
No sort of energy other than
the sum of energies in the (mumbles).
But still you see such
a really big movement.
And you can consider this as sort of
a shortcut of active transport.
So E1 calcium form is
a starting conditions
and the E2 state you can consider that
after the calcium binding.
So there are several things clearly occur.
One important thing is that this open,
sort of headpiece, closes
in the absence of calcium.
Also this long helix,
this green one,
it's called M5 helix as I mentioned,
so this very long helix
sort of bows this direction
in the absence of calcium.
And the third thing I should
mention, that this movement,
right, this cyan Helix is M4 helix.
As I showed in this previous slide,
that M4 helix forms a very important part
of a calcium binding site.
It uses a main chain oxygen atoms.
So if it really moves, then
perhaps this calcium also moves.
What we see here is that
this M4 helix moves.
Like this.
I have to introduce this
numbering of the helices,
because otherwise you can't
refer to the structure well.
So the left hand side
is the more simplified representations.
I used cylinder instead
of ribbons or spirals
to represent the alpha helices.
What we see here is this M4
helix, M4L, it move like this.
And it is easier to see the movement,
perhaps, from the side.
So M4 helix is here, like this.
The calcium is located there,
in the calcium bound form,
and must be released, like this.
So for we see here is a kind
of piston-like movement.
So it's really like mechanical pumps.
I mentioned two things,
big differences in the E1 to E2 movement.
And so M5 bent rather larger
towards M1 is located here.
So, it's bent like this.
Right?
Here you see this part.
M5 sort of bends.
Like this.
And M3 and M4 move together
to the lumenal side
by one turn of alpha helix.
I did not mention this one,
but M6 rotates by 90 degrees or so.
By doing this, what we see here
is the number of oxygen atoms
that possibly contribute to
make calcium binding site.
In the calcium bound form,
five oxygen atoms from
amino acid side chains,
and two water molecules form site one.
And in the site two, four
side chain's oxygen atoms
and three main chain
oxygen atoms form site two.
As I mentioned, by the
mutagenesis experiment removing
only one of this side chain oxygen atoms
would completely destroy
the calcium binding ability.
And, in this configuration, it certainly
has only four oxygen
atom can make this site,
if the number of water molecules the same.
And that applies to site two also.
So that nicely explains
lower affinity of this state.
So the mechanism is here.
As I mentioned, we need a catch state,
occlude state,
and release state.
And this one is correspond
to E1 to calcium form.
And this one correspond to the E2 form.
And very old Tanford model
is something like this.
So it perhaps requires a very small change
of calcium coordination.
(mumbles) Catch the calcium
some charge residues
will be arranged so it makes
a very nice coordination of calcium.
For when it's released,
perhaps it requires just a small change.
So maybe this helix twisted,
or inclined,
so that the coordination
geometry become poor
and will decrease the affinity.
And it's not really the case.
And this is my model,
I thought, initially.
Because part of the helix actually broken.
It may be possible to
sort of extend this part.
And then the calcium
coordination will be worse,
and will be released.
But, in fact, we found it's not like this.
It moves, like that, right,
like mechanical pumps.
And so, let's see, how it's made.
And the three things I
mentioned, how they are related.
One of the key thing is this
M5 helix, it's a very long one,
and so it bends like that.
It is sort of integrated
into the P-domain,
we are now looking at the P-domain here.
So the phosphorylation
is this aspartate 351,
is located here.
This M5 helix, be a long
transmembrane helix,
has a (mumbles) in here.
And also M4 helix,
that's the helix really
makes the site two,
calcium binding site,
it's sort of connected to M5 helix
by forming this kind of sheet structures.
So something happens here,
will be transmitted to these
transmembrane helices easily.
And also, something
happens somewhere there,
will be transmitted to
phosphorylation site also.
So, it's a mechanical links.
This one compares to two states,
and to calcium bound
form is always violet,
and the E2 form is always green.
Like this.
By superimposing these two structure
we see that M5 bends like that,
and M4 moves together
and then the M4 kicks
the M2 helix in the one state.
So it's a violet ones.
The M2 helix cannot stay there.
So that has to move like this.
And that also moves the M1 helix.
So it's a kind of molecular
dominoes takes place here.
So it's a very large
global confirmation change.
But important thing is
what you really need
is changing the curvature
of this M5 helix.
And also, it is possible to
explain the downward movement
of M4 helix by very simple
geometric causing and (mumbles).
And M4 and M5 helix
integrated into P-domain.
So if the M5 helix moves
from this position to that position,
then the P-domain inclines.
That pushes the M4 helix.
This is actually the
mechanism it really used.
And I hope you remember that
the inclination of the P-domain
will move the M4 helix downward.
That is the key movement, really is.
So the next thing is
one of the main events,
the ATP binding.
Of course this is something wrong here,
because this inner domain start to move
to just catch the ATP here.
In the real case, the ATP
binds much earlier in the step.
That's sort of an artifact
of the interpolation.
Anyway.
I want to stress is that the three things.
Here, the open headpiece
becomes compact again.
And the second thing is that
this blue one, M1 helix,
is sort of put upwards by ATP binding.
And this part, the top
part, sort of bends.
Like that.
And it is easier to see
this movement from side.
So the binding of ATP,
this blue ones, so-called M1 to M2 helix,
brought up into the cytoplasm
and form the kind of V-shaped structures.
And this part, I call M1 dash, M1 prime,
becomes a very short helix,
it slides on the top of
the membrane's surface.
And it's clearly facilitated
by the A-domain movement.
And if you look at the A-domain like this,
this is the A2 helix, sort
of rotates, like that.
So the A-domain is actually
tilts by the ATP binding.
Like this.
I think on more thing I should stress
that the movement of this link.
By tilting of this A-domain
it pulls these things;
M1, M2, and M3 links.
So these flexible links
are all pulled up and perhaps strained.
So in the chemical reaction putting strain
causes the reaction to go through fast.
So this very similar maneuver
is used for making the
reaction forward here.
I did not mention that
just the carbon binding
of calcium does not close
this cytoplasmic gate.
And this site two calcium
is actually exchangeable
with the calcium ions in the cytoplasm.
This spheres represent the water molecules
bound in the crystal.
It means that the water
can reach this part,
and also that means the calcium
perhaps be able to come this point.
So this is a wider view of this area.
And you see two calcium ions here.
And you see these red spheres
represent water molecules
around this binding site.
So this one is the glutamate
that's capping this calcium.
So there is plenty of space
for the glutamate side chain
to change it's confirmation.
So it may change confirmation
this way to that way,
then this calcium may be able
to get out from here to there
and the new one comes in.
So it means that the cytoplasmic gate
is not really closed in this state.
But here, we see in this state,
this space is occupied by
another large side chain,
a hydrophobic residues.
Here you find leucines and leucines.
And it has no space for
this glutamate side chain
to change it's confirmation.
And to do that the enzyme actually moves
the whole helix here.
Not just one residue, the
ATPase moves the whole helix.
That's the one we saw
in the previous movies.
So it's now clear that
calcium cannot get out.
So this must be the
mechanism of occlusion.
So the gate mechanism
is the gate closure of
the cytoplasmic gate.
This movement is certainly
facilitated by binding of ATP.
Cause actually we used this
nonhydrolyzable analog of ATP.
So-called AMPPCP.
So usually oxygen must be here,
but in this one it's carbon atom here.
And it's located near the hinge
between the the N-domain and the P-domain
and cross-links these two domains.
This is a more detailed view.
The point here is that ATP,
the adine ending binds to this green one,
it's the N-domain,
and the phosphate region
binds to P-domain.
So it's a cross-link really.
So if the ATP gamma phosphate transferred,
so this bond is cleaved,
then there is perhaps
no need for the enzyme
to keep this confirmation.
So the enzyme it will be released.
So, in a way, this ATP analog cross-links
the P and the N-domains so that the
(coughs)
phosphorylate transfer
can be able to take place.
And also important is this
magnesium ion, metal ions here.
Why important is shown here.
This, again, is a difficult
picture, busy picture.
Because the P-domain of the
two states are superimposed.
E1 calcium form is shown always in violet.
So this yellow one is the AMPPCP form.
We see here is that the
binding of nucleotide
and magnesium bends the domain.
You see the orientation of this M4
as a P6 helix and P7 helix.
It bends like that.
For it's important is A-domain
and P-domain interacts
only this point!
So one of the end of the A-domain
is sitting almost on this helix.
So it changes a bit, only slightly.
Maybe 20 degrees or so.
But because this change occurs
near this pivoting point,
some change somewhere
here must be very large.
And that's really the case.
In the previous movie I
show that by binding of ATP
the A-domain rotates like that.
But the change here is very small.
Just 20 degrees or so in
bending of the P-domain.
That brings the A-domain so much.
The angle is at 20 degrees
or something like that,
but the movement is very large.
It's large enough for bringing up
this M2 and M5 helices like this.
So the next step is a real main
event, the calcium release.
And that happens here is
110 degrees or so rotation
of the A-domain.
This time it's horizontal rotations.
See here the A2 helix moves like that.
And what happens is that
rotation is transmitted
to this V-shaped structure
formed by M1, M2 helices.
And that this M1 helix sort of pushes
this M4 helix like that.
As I mentioned, that the key movement
is the downward movement of
M4 and M3 helices like this.
That we saw in the E1
calcium to E2 equilibriums.
So what happens here is
that the A-domain rotates,
it moves this V-shaped structure,
and that moves this M1, M3 helices.
And how it is done?
So this is just a top
view of this rotation.
So the start point here, E1P state.
So you look at this cylinder
representing A2 helix.
It's original position is here.
And after it becomes E2P
state it comes this position.
So very large alterations.
And one more thing I should mention,
in E1P state, both gates are closed.
And this state, cytoplasmic gate is closed
but lumenal gate is opened.
And, this state, both
gates are closed again.
So I mentioned this one.
The lumenal gate is
closed in this E1P analog.
And this one, it's barium fluoride,
and E2-P ground state analogs.
And this one, aluminum fluoride,
and it's transition state analog.
I show you some detail
in few minutes later.
So by rotating this one,
0 degree to 90 degrees,
what we see here is that
this V-shaped structure
moves from this position to that positions
and pushes this M3 and M4 helix like that.
And that causes the
opening of a lumenal gate.
And how this movement and
this movement are related
is an important questions.
Let's think about this kind of movement.
And also is important
is the actually shape of this P-domain.
P-domain, you see it's ridge-like shape.
Has a ridge-like shape, right?
And the A-domain moving on
the top surface of this ridge.
So what happens is in the E1P positions
this A-domain is located here.
And in the E2P form it come. like this.
So if the P-domain is fixed, and M-domain,
M1 helix for example, is moveable,
then by moving this it simply lift
the transmembrane helices.
But if this transmembrane helices
want to stay in the membrane
and P-domain can change it's inclination.
What happens is that the
P-domain comes this positions.
Keeping this M1 helix
at the same position.
And, for I mentioned, is in
the E1, E2, P, A2 equilibrium
the P-domain inclines
and pushes M4 downward.
So that's the key event.
And here, certainly we
see that kind of movement.
And what causes such downward movement
is that the M1 helix want to stay
in the main transmembrane region.
Maybe I go back to this
movie to see you again.
Here you see these things,
green one the P-domains.
You see it inclines to
move toward the membrane
when the A-domain moves
in to this directions.
So this is a mechanism that
opening of the lumenal gate.
So A-domain rotates, it moves
this V-shaped structure also,
(coughs)
and at the same time,
because this A-domain rotates like this
and M1, M2 helices stays in the membrane,
so it inclines the P-domain
and that causes this M4 helix downwards.
And pushes down the M4 helix.
And that make (mumbles) lumenal gating.
If you look at from the
side, that really happens.
Cause the A-domain rotates this way,
at the same time P-domain inclines
because M1 or M2 helices stay there
and the M5 helix certainly
allows that kind of inclinations.
So that's the M5 helix designed.
So this is just a open state.
This is occluded stages.
You can not have space to
water or calcium to get in.
But here you see a rather large opening
and calcium can get released
through this gate.
The second step, this
does from here to there.
What happens here,
you now compare this E2
barium fluoride structure
to aluminium fluoride structures.
What you see here is M2 helix unwinding.
And M2 helix is continuous
helix in this state.
But here it's broken into two pieces.
Because a helix is a very
long, winding structure,
so it needs many residue
to span certain distance.
But if you extend like this,
it easily allows five
angstroms of downward movement.
So that actually happen here.
So you see that M1 position
of this end of the V-shaped structure
changes from this position
to that positions.
And that causes a
downward movement M1 helix
from this position to that positions.
So it presses this M4 helix
to close the lumenal gate.
So the mechanism here is that
the M2 helix has a switch.
The helix to coil transition
(mumbles) occurs here.
And that allows this V-shaped structure
to go downward and close the gate.
At the same time this
rotation does one more thing,
or two more things actually.
By doing this very large
rotation, what we now see
is what happens around
phosphorylation site.
This is a magnified view of this area.
(coughs)
By 110 degree rotation rotations
the one loop,
so-called TGES loop, I write in here,
comes into this positions and
occupies where the ADP was.
So it's clearly preventing
the rebinding of ADP,
and for the ADP to be able to rebind,
whole structure has to be moved.
That must be a quite big movement.
So the backward reaction here is prevented
by physically bringing in
and prevents the backward reaction.
So that seems to be the way
this enzyme really works.
There are two ways for enzyme
to facilitate the catalysis.
One way is to, of course,
accelerate the forward reaction.
The other possibility is to
prevent the backward reaction.
And here we see several places
that mechanism for preventing
backward reactions.
Anyway, by going from this
position to that position
also we see an electrostatic catch.
And the P-domain and the A-domain
forms interface in this region.
We see a charge residues arginine,
and on the other side it's aspartate
and the other place is also this arginine,
and here it use main chain atom,
but we see an electrostatic catch.
So electrostatic is a
long-range interactions.
It may be able to catch the A-domain
moving in this direction,
and just stabilize there.
So, many thing actually occur here.
And this movement must be related
to hydrolysis of aspartylphosphate.
What I wanted to show is
that aspartate, where it is,
near here.
This is aspart 351,
and forms a triangular things
pointing downwards here
because this is a sort
of covalent bond form.
The first oxygen atom
of phosphate is here.
And this has a magnesium here.
And this is a ground state.
In the transition state the
movement must be very small
because that's just the inversion
of these triangular things.
And in this transition state analog
it's a planar things.
You see here, it's a
planar phosphate analogs.
So this is the transition state,
and certainly we now see
these water molecules
in the perfect position to attack
the transition state analogs.
And we also see a glutamate here.
It's glutamate can work as
a general base and/or acid
and activate this water molecule.
And in this state this glutamate
is pointing sort of inward
of this loop and can not make
this kind of interactions.
So the things move in here is very small,
but we now see a water
molecule comes in here.
That force causes the change of movement,
the change of this loop, it's a TGES loop.
And TGES loop is one of
the signature sequence
of a P-type ATPases.
It's very important for
hydrolysis of aspartylphosphate.
These Ys here,
the glutamate (mumbles)
activates water molecules,
and also stabilizes state
in these confirmations.
So this is just a space fill model.
And in the E2P ground state
it's completely occupied
by protein and magnesium and
this case it's beryl fluoride
on here.
So no space for the water to
get in to make hydrolysis.
So the transition state
we see this water molecule
can attack this transition
state analogous phosphate
just enough for just
one water molecule here.
So, this is a rather small change,
but it's really functionally
has a big meaning.
And now I show you a animations.
I hope you see it now a bit better.
So this is of ground state of E2P.
The tilt, squiggle,
means of transition state
and dot P-I stands for the product state.
And for is important
is in the ground state
the triangular things point downwards,
and transition states become planar,
and then the production
state it's got like this.
So we now see a chemical
reaction of aspartylphosphate
in (mumbles) details.
So the movement of water
molecule moves the TGES group,
that causes the hydrolysis and also causes
the movement of adenine farther.
It correlates the hydrolysis
of aspartate to gating things.
So this is E2 PT2 transition.
So you see the gate is closed
by release of phosphate.
So the summary is like this.
The A-domain is the actuator
of the transmembrane gates.
Its position and orientation
are regulated by domain interface.
And it's really the gating mechanism.
And ATP, phosphate, magnesium, and calcium
are main modifiers of the interface.
But it doesn't tell you
why such large and complicated
movements necessary.
What does ATP do?
It's relatively easy to understand.
The ATP is a cleavable cross-linker
that bridges the N and P-domain.
It tilts the A-domain and places strain
on the A-domain M3 link.
I maybe forgot to mention that this
is really the driving force
of the A-domain rotation.
Because if you cut this link
by proteolysis no rotation,
or no ATP hydrolysis takes place.
But this seems to need
only the structure of ATP.
And where the energy
of ATP hydrolysis goes?
That's a quite interesting
and important question
I give you as a subject to think about.
And the reason why such large
and complicated main movements
are necessary is here.
So the answer is perhaps
ion pumps fluctuate so much
by thermal energy yet you
have to utilize it effectively
for transporting ions.
To explain this to you
I show you molecular dynamic simulations.
And this is a real system.
So the one calcium ATPase molecule put
in the explicit lipid bi-layers,
and water molecules, and salt.
And this one is 150
millimolar potassium chloride.
And the blue one is potassium,
and the red ones is perhaps chloride.
But you see even at 150 millimolar
the number of ions is fairly small.
So if it's a 10 millimolar
of even micromolar calcium,
the chances for getting this
enzyme must be very small.
But still, it functions.
And the computation power we
have is something like this.
And because this is a huge system,
although I have a quite good ones,
and I can make 5 parallel computations,
I can simulate 0.4 nanoseconds per day.
Well, you remember from yesterday's talk
the calcium ATPase needs 30 milliseconds
to go through one cycle.
So if you divide that
number (laughs) by this one
you can't sort of imagine
that the calculation
will be done within
your lifetime. (laughs)
But still it gives you a very good insight
on how it really works.
So this is the 30 nanosecond simulations.
And this tiny violet
spheres represent calciums.
So you see so much movement here.
Also these domains fluctuate so much.
And in the next one I show you
a magnified view of that
area, calcium binding region.
You see it's very shaking so much.
And these small, small red spheres
represent water molecules
that attack this site
two calcium continuously.
Only this glutamate side chain prevent
the water molecule will
attack this calcium.
As I mentioned,
in this state the cytoplasmic
gate is not really closed.
So if this glutamate side
chain change it's confirmation,
open,
allows access of water
molecules to this one,
perhaps whole system allows this calcium
to pop out and new one to come in.
So it's quite, perhaps easy to understand.
So even though the simulation is limited
you can get a quite good
insight how it really works.
So this is a taking home message.
Ion pumps work, oh, English
is wrong, but nevermind.
Ion pumps work in the
thermally fluctuating world,
yet they utilize thermal
energy effectively
for transporting ions.
And to do that I think it's
quite important to mention
that they use flexible links
between the A-domain and
these transmembrane helices.
And pressed strain
for driving the movement
to one directions.
So if it's a flexible link
perhaps you can not press this
so that the reactions go
back to the previous state.
So putting strain on the flexible link
seems to be the way to prevent
the backward reaction also.
And also perhaps cooperatively binding
the nucleotide and magnesium
also prevent the backward reactions.
So for the important part it
use the helix-helix contact.
But for driving to the one directions
it seems to use the
strains on flexible links.
So the nature uses same maneuver
to make the reaction proceed.
And in the simple chemical reactions
if the molecule is distorted and strained
then the chances for this
molecule to break is much higher.
So it's similar thing is
used for different purposes.
But in a way I think the
principle is the same.
So I think I'd like to thank you
for your attentions and stop here.
(audience claps)(upbeat electronic music)